لا تبكي يا صغيري. فويل لكل فاسد
نهش في لحم العراق. صوت صافرات
الانذار ونداءات استغاثة تنبئ
بعملية مداهمة لمحاولات تهريب
للنفط. مشهد استمر لسنين. ما زال
عالقا في عقول العراقيين يصور
مأساة يعيشها العراق هي الاكثر
تعقيدا واستنزافا على ثاني اكبر
منتجي اوبك وصاحب خامس اكبر
احتياطي نفطي في العالم بعد
فنزويلا والسعودية وكندا وايران
كيف كان ذلك لم يكن الهدف النظام
السياسي الحكيم بل كان النفط
الذي لم يكن يوما لاهله. بلد
النفط والطاقة الذي تدخلت في
مصيره الدول حتى بات اليوم
يستورد طاقته من الخارج من عشرة
ملايين يعيشون تحت خط الفقر
خلافات سياسية تنعكس اثارها على
ارضه وتشل اقتصاده. بوتين الذي
حكم العالم بالنفط ها هو الان
يصيب العالم بمجاعة طاقة عالمية
يصيح الغرب من المها الى هذه
اللحظة. وكل ساق سيسقى بما سقى.
نفط العراق. في عام العراق بات
يتذمر من الشراكة مع الغرب وها
هو صدام حسين يستفزهم بفتح
الصنبور النفطي واغلاقه حسب
مصلحة بلاده ويظهر في باله
احتمال بان يقوم بسحب النفط
العراقي من السوق لفترة طويلة من
الزمن من اجل الاضرار بالاسعار.
هنا لا يزال العراق يمارس نفوذ
مزعزعا لاستقرار التدفقات
النفطية من الشرق الاوسط الى
الاسواق الدولية. كما ابدى صدام
حسين استعداده لاستخدام صادرات
بلاده من الخام للتلاعب باسواق
النفط. وهذا سيؤدي الى توطيد
اركان حكمه وتعزيز صورته كزعيم
عربي والضغط على الاخرين من اجل
رفع العقوبات الاقتصادية
المفروضة على نظامه. ولكن يبدو
ان الامر لم يعجب احدهم. نعم يا
سادة. انها الولايات الامريكية
وبريطانيا. صدام حسين كان شوكة
عالقة في حدوقهم يغصون بها اذا
ما ارادوا الاتهام اكثر ويعتقدون
ان الشكل المستقبلي للصناعة
العراقية سيؤثر على اسواق النفط
وعلى فاعلية اوبك. لذا بدأوا
باطلاق انذارهم يجب ان نحرص على
فتح قطاع النفط امام الاستثمار
الاجنبي. فمشاركة الشركات
الاجنبية الحل الوحيد لجعل
العراق مصدرا موثوقا للنفط.
الامر سيكون حساسا من الناحية
السياسية وسيتطلب منا معالجة
دقيقة كي لا نعطي انطباعا باننا
نحاول دفع العراقيين نحو مسار
معين. في يناير من عام الفين
وثلاثة اي قبل شهرين من الاحتلال
الامريكي البريطاني للعراق ليقف
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني توني
بلير امام اعضاء العموم. ويخطب
فيهم قائلا ان السبب الذي يقف
وراء اتخاذ نال ذلك الاجراء لا
علاقة له بالنفط او باي من
نظريات المؤامرة الاخرى التي
يروج لها البعض. اما شريكه في
الحرب الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
جورج بوش يصرح في مؤتمر صحفي عام
الفين وستة قائلا نفط العراق
ينتمي لشعبه. وعلى الحكومة
العراقية ان تحافظ على الاصل
الثمين. اما بعد لم تعد الاطماع
الامريكية والبريطانية في النفط
العراقي والتي كانت جزءا من
الاسباب الفعلية لغزو العراق
واحتلاله سرية او محض شائعات
واصبح العالم اجمع على يقين
بانهم لم يغزوا العراق كي يأكلوا
التين بل انهم يريدون نهب ثروات
بلد تطفو على بحر من النفط. كان
همهم القضاء على سياسات الرئيس
الصارم الذي حاول جاهدا الحفاظ
على ثروات بلاده بعيدا عن يد
الطامعين الاطاحة بصدام حسين.
كانت جائزة كبرى لبريطانيا
وامريكا. فبعد سقوطه سيحصلون على
امدادات نفطية هائلة تم حل
الامر. رحل صدام شوكتهم العالقة
رحل من كان درع البلاد. غيروا
القوانين دمروا البلاد وبات يلقى
بثرواتها في حجر الشركات الغربية
لعقود وهكذا تم الامر. ما حدث
للعراق لم يكن مؤامرة. وفقط
الطريقة التي يتم بها تنفيذ مثل
هذه الامور. سيطرت الشركات
الغربية على النفط. وعزز
الامريكان موقفهم الجيوستراتيجي
وسالت دماء العراقيين على ضفاف
دجلة والفرات ومع النفط. ولكن كل
ذي حق سوف ياخذ حقه. ها هي اليوم
امريكا والغرب سوف تأتي مهرولة
على قدم وساق لتستنجد بالعراق
بعد الحرب الاوكرانية الروسية
والعقوبات التي تم فرضها على
روسيا اكبر منتجي النفط في
العالم في خضم تفاقم الازمة
يرتفع الطلب على النفط الخام.
ومن غير شك سوف تتحول انظار
المشترين الى منطقة الشرق اوسط
خاصة العراق لتوفر بديلا للنفط
الروسي. صحيح ان العراق لا يمكن
مقارنته بروسيا ثاني اكبر مصدر
للنفط للصين في حين ان العراق هو
ثالث اكبر مصدر للصين وتاتي
السعودية في المرتبة الاولى الا
ان بوتين استطاع اذلال الغرب
واغلق صنفور نفطه ليعود الى بحار
العراق النفطي دليلين خانعين ليس
لهم وجهة ولن يشفق عليهم احد سوى
العراق. العراق الذي كان اكبر
مصدر للنفط في العالم اما ان له
ان يسترد مكانته? من سرقة النفط
الى الجفاف. لكن انتظروا قليلا.
لا بد من حل بعض الامور. اتذكرون
الارض الواقعة بين النهرين? نعم
اهلا بكم في العراق. البلد الذي
كان يتمتع بامكان الوصول الى
المياه الوفيرة منذ فجر الحضارة.
اما بعد فقد شهد ازمة مياه اشتدت
في العامين الماضيين نتيجة عوامل
عديدة منها سياسية واخرى بيئية
حولته من بلد يعرف بوفرة المياه
الى بلد يعاني الجفاف. جفاف دمر
الاف الاراضي الزراعية وزاد من
معدل التصحر وادى الى نزوح مئات
العائلات التي تكسب من الزراعة
وصيد الاسماك. يبدو ان الحكومة
العراقية مجبرة في ملف الامن
المائي على معالجة جملة من
القضايا من بينها الاضطرابات
السياسية والتحديات الامنية
والازمة الاقتصادية والخلافات مع
دول الجوار. السياسات المائية
لتركيا وايران هي ما ادت الى خفض
امدادات المياه في العراق مما
اثر على الزراعة وزيادة تلوث في
معظم مناطق البلاد لم يكتفي
العراق من سياسات الخارج بل حتى
سياساته بالداخل كانت سببا في
حرمان اهله ومزارعيه المياه
وتحويل بلادهم الى ارض قاحلة
فساد كبير سوء ادارة تغير مناخ.
زيادة عدد سكانه تربص خارجي. كل
هذا واكثر حرم العراق من حقه
المتبقي من المياه لتجف اراضيه
لحيلته امام هذا الوضع المأساوي.
الصراع على السلطة. بلد يمضي
تسعة اشهر بل اكثر دون حكومة
جديدة بعد رحيل صدام حسين. تنهش
به دول كثيرة وتستخدمه ساحة
لتصفية حساباتها. تزيد فيه
المواجهة من الفشل السياسي في
بلد يعاني من تردي الخدمات
العامة وارتفاع معدل الفقر
وانتشار البطالة على الرغم من
الثروة النفطية الهائلة وعدم
وجود صراع كبير منذ هزيمة تنظيم
الدولة الاسلامية قبل خمس سنوات.
انه العراق. يعاني اليوم من صراع
كبير على السلطة بين رجل الدين
الشيعي مقتدى الصدر وخصومه
الشيعة المدعومين من ايران مع
اقتحام انصاره البرلمان وبدء
اعتصام مفتوح ليعود الخلاف من
جديد من سيشكل الحكومة المقبلة
ويؤدي الى تفاقم الشقاق في
المجتمع الشيعي الذي يهيمن على
السياسة العراقية منذ غزو
الولايات المتحدة والاطاحة
بالرئيس الراحل صدام حسين عام
الفين وثلاثة. الوضع يا سادة في
اسوأ حالاته وما ان تسمع به حتى
تنهار الدموع بحرقة بلد النفط
والاثار يعاني اليوم من صراعات
تنهمر عليه واحدة تلو الاخرى.
فما كان ينتهي ويتعافى من حربه
الضارية وسرقة نفطه وسلب ارضه
وتدمير اثاره حتى وصل الى جفافه.
جفاف مؤلم يحل على ارضه وقلوب
شعبه. جفاف يسيطر على بلد تتحكم
في مياهه. دول اخرى تضع يدها على
عنقه تحاول خنقه. يصرخ من عطشه
وقلة حيلته في وقت تتكالب فيه
الدول لتسيطر على ثرواته. بلد
ليس له نظام يحميه او حكومة
تقويه ويحتمي بها تحت مظلته. بلد
فقد كل ما يملك بغمضة عين. فقد
نفطه فبات فقيرا فقد مياهه فبات
عطشانا. واليوم يفقد شعبه الذي
بدأ يثور من فساد ادارته. لكنه
سيتعافى كما سبق له وسيخرج صدام
حسين من نفوس التائرين ليعيدوا
العراق الى ما كان عليه شوكة في
حلق المعتدين.